The media's always looking for something to
blame.
In part it's motivated by a political desire
to find a group that isn't politically active
or politically powerful
as a scapegoat.
The Department of Justice is at the Phillips
house taking all their ammunition and their guns.
So they have my guns outside, taking pictures
of it where the neighbors are driving by.
In the wake of mass shootings, our media and
our politicians tend to focus on two things:
banning certain kinds of weapons
and keeping weapons out of the hands of certain
kinds of people.
None of us want crazy people having guns,
look what happened.
I'm afraid that that semi-automatic weapon
is going to fall in tot he hands of a crazy person.
A dozen more killers, a hundred more?
How can we possibly even guess how many given
our nation's refusal
to create an active national database of the
mentally ill.
That's Wayne LaPierre, head spokesperson for
the National Rifle Association.
An active national database of the mentally
ill.
Even the nation's premiere gun lobby believes
that a database
to keep guns away from the mentally ill seems
like a good idea.
Better safe than sorry, it seems, well, logical.
But what if there's a serious flaw in that
logic.
There is no evidence that the mentally ill
account for a largely disproportionate amount
of violence or gun violence.
Here's the entire population of people with
a mental illness diagnosis
and when you control for the complicating
factor of substance abuse
here's the number of them statistically likely
to commit a violent act.
Only about four percent.
General strategies that forensic psychiatrists
take
is that one never attempts to predict violence
in a large pool of un-selected individuals.
If you have a test that is 90% accurate and
you applied it to a hundred thousand people
the rate of violence is roughly half a percent
in the general population.
So there are five hundred real violent people,
but you've identified ten thousand people
inappropriately as being violent.
In the absence of a history of violence or
any other risk factors
it is impossible to identify who will go on
to become violent.
For every individual who goes on a shooting
rampage
there are a hundred or perhaps more individuals
who also had disturbed relationships with
teachers, parents.
Authorities want to know what caused the alleged
gunman Jared Lee Loughner to snap.
We hear it over and over again.
If he'd been transported to a psych ward,
the shootings might never have happened.
There were clear warning signs.
Here to talk about the warning signs in a
case like this-
Should we have been picking up some signs
on this guy-
-we should be looking for in an individual
like this?
Once we know the outcome, it is easy to look
back and perceive a pattern
that seems to be leading to a common event.
Often that's simply hindsight bias.
If we put doctors in a position of acting
on behalf of the government
or acting on behalf of social control.
Then that undermines the therapeutic mission.
Restricting the rights to people who are living
with a mental illness
or possibly maybe diagnosed with a mental
illness
just further perpetuates people not receiving
or seeking
the treatment that they need to get better
and we know prevention, early intervention
and seeking that treatment right on the onset
is what supports people in recovery.
So most people with mental illnesses never
do anything violent
and it's almost impossible to predict who's
going to snap without a prior history of violence.
But still, what's the harm in taking precautions?
To answer that question, we turn to California.
California's Armed Prohibited Persons System
aims to confiscate guns from three groups:
Those with a history of violence.
Wanted criminals.
And anyone the state believes has a severe
mental illness.
Because one nurse wrote false information,
now I'm on a prohibited persons list.
I've never done anything to hurt anybody.
Lynette Phillips and her husband David have
never committed a violent crime
and Lynette is certainly not a wanted felon.
But she does have a mental illness.
I was diagnosed about 13 years ago with anxiety
disorder.
Once I was diagnosed I felt
'okay this makes sense now, this excessive
worrying.'
And once the medication started taking effect,
I felt like a normal person.
Lynette ran into trouble when she switched
her medication from a pill to a patch.
She rushed the transition because she wanted
to be well in time for her first Christmas
with a new grand daughter.
What ended up happening was I couldn't stop
crying and there wasn't anything I saw, experienced,
everything would make me cry.
Desperate to stop crying, Lynette asked her
son to find a hospital for her to check herself into
so she could stabilize her mood.
The local hospital was full so they ended
up at a facility called Aurora Charter Oak.
That's where my nightmare started, I thought
my nightmare crying was-
That was a piece of cake.
I was admitted based on me being suicidal,
that I could potentially drive my car off a cliff.
Which I never said those words, the nurse
never said those words.
So where the cliff came in to play, I don't
know.
Once I said goodbye to my husband, once I
got to the unit,
they did their assessment and started giving
me paperwork
and that's when I realized I was being, I
was 5150, involuntarily being admitted.
Despite voluntarily seeking treatment, Lynette
was involuntarily committed to the hospital.
Representatives at Aurora Charter Oak declined
to comment for this story.
But Lynette says she was released before the
full 72 hours,
once the hospital psychiatrist actually had
a chance to see her.
He said better policies and procedures should
be in effect so this doesn't happen.
Nobody apologized, that's closest to an apology
as I got.
Lynette has a letter from her personal psychiatrist
backing up her claim that she sought treatment
voluntarily.
But because of the involuntary commitment,
she suddenly became an armed prohibited person.
California Department of Justice officers
showed up with no warrant
and took every gun in the house.
I don't even know what gun it was I bought
for Dave for Christmas.
Couldn't have told you.
Never loaded a gun.
You bring nine officers to the house, you
surround the house, how much is that costing?
They didn't need to do that, they embarrassed
us in the neighborhood.
It is humiliating when someone comes to your
door and treats you like a criminal.
It's not how we should be treating people
who are living with an illness.
To the extent that society continues to vilify
the mentally ill
and to scapegoat them as being the primary
cause of gun violence
is a major step backward.
There needs to be some better policing of
who they're coming after.